12 est à présent face à la première
[Musique]
les élections pour le renouvellement des
assemblées des collectivités locales
auront elles bien lieu en juin
nous pouvons nous le demandent et ses
échéances et il ya été replanté dans
toute la france à cause de l'épidémie
provoquée par le virus coville 19 la
campagne électorale pourra-t-elle se
tenir dans des conditions normales si
nous sommes limités dans nos
déplacements
en attendant la décision définitive
quand faut-il retenir des réalisations
de la ctm comment améliorer son
fonctionnement allons nous vers une
nouvelle offre politique sous la forme
d'une union sacrée entre nos courants
politiques comme cela est dans l'air
depuis quelques jours je vous propose de
passer en revue toutes ces questions
avec trois élus de la collectivité
territoriale de la tunique dans le cadre
de notre série d'émissions sur le bilan
et les perspectives de cette institution
dont c'est le huitième volet aujourd'hui
bienvenue en face avant première en ce
dimanche 31 janvier pour un nouveau
numéro de l'émission politique
hebdomadaire de la rédaction de
martinique la première le jeu vous
pourrez entre nos invités à cette
émission réalisée par adel le douaisis
le curieux tout d'abord on alphabétique
jenny dulys petit bonjour là bonjour je
manque parti met ainsi le me recevoir
madame le maire madame la maire madame
le mien je préfère mais certains
préfèrent madame la maire je respecte
non madame la maire donc du morne rouge
vous est également conseillère à
l'assemblée de martinique vous êtes élu
dans les rangs de l'opposition au pmn
ensemble pour une martinique nouvelle
vous êtes une des membres dirigeants du
mouvement aux ont osé lancer papillon
petit au milieu des années 1990 mais en
homme en rouge depuis 2008 deux premiers
en femme concilier en général en 2005 de
1993 et vous avez également siéger à la
région
je conclus cette brève présentation
disant que vous êtes enseignante de
métier et vous avez terminé votre
carrière comme directrice du couvent
notre dame de la délivrande durant le
rouge bien entendu pour norouz votre
terroir 6 à une soutane bonjour madame
c'est tout
bonjour bonjour à tous les les auditeurs
et auditrices martin première permettez
moi de leur souhaiter une très bonne
année de santé de sérénité et de
réussite et une émotion particulière
pour notre jeune jonathan du collège
hyacinthe beauville qui et qui a été
enterré vendredi
vous êtes membre du conseil exécutif de
la 7e et vous parlez en particulier de
ce collège
il affrontait puisque vous êtes en
particulier chargé de l'éducation vous
allez nous expliquer tout à l'heure de
quoi il s'agit qu'est ce que vous faites
est exactement au sein de ce conseil
exécutif
je rappelle que vous êtes militant du
mouvement bas payés en chasse présidée
par yan monplaisir vous est implantée à
rivière salée
vous avez été adjointe au maire d'entre
eux le sillon de 2011 à 2014 et vous
êtes également enseignante mais vous
avez terminé votre carrière comme
directrice de l'école élémentaire de
petits bonds d'origine en salle et au
niveau a précisé
au terme de trente huit années
d'exercice vous êtes bien renseigné
je me demande quel est votre métier ben
moi aussi je me pose la question
bonjour bonjour à tous les auditeurs et
auditrices d'un matinée que la première
et je veux l'on suit et mes meilleurs
voeux pour cette nouvelle année des
voeux de santé de bonheur de réussite et
puis c'est vrai que cette année 2020 qui
vient de passer a été particulièrement
difficile
alors je le landais de ne pas baisser
les bras et d'être toujours debout et
une pensée particulière aussi pour tous
les habitants du nord qui ont été
touchées par les intempéries que nous
connaissons voilà donc que des dossiers
d'indemnisation ne sont toujours pas
réglés
vous êtes la deuxième vice président de
l'assemblée de martinique donc membre du
bureau élu de la majorité
bien entendu secrétaire général adjoint
du rdr mme le rassemblement démocratique
pour la martinique dont le secrétaire
général et claude d'esclans devise qui
en ce 31 janvier est concerné par un
certain 10 ans événement heureux c'est
son anniversaire aujourd'hui
quand la claude lise 91 ans président de
l'assemblée de martinique depuis
décembre 2015
vous êtes implanté vous même à fort de
france dont vous êtes originaire et vous
exercer le métier de bibliothèque
alors madame
avant de rentrer dans le vif du sujet
sur la 7ème quelques questions
d'actualité précédemment que le nom le
centre et le sud sont reposantes et
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est important
de se définir par rapport à un terroir
ou madame tout le set on a effectivement
un ancrage politique mais en tant qu'élu
de la collectivité territoriale j'ai
vraiment à coeur d'avoir un regard
global sur l'ensemble du territoire
d'autant que dans ma fonction de cause
de d'élus à la collectivité mais plus
précisément plus aisément de présidente
du comité de l'eau et de la biodiversité
on voit bien qu'il y a effectivement
cette jonction qui doit être établi sur
le territoire puisque l'eau vient
majoritairement grande panthier du nom
et elle doit être déversée sur
l'ensemble du territoire sur le sud et
sur le centre donc c'est vraiment cette
transversalité sur un gain global qu'il
faut avoir sur le territoire parce que
je pense que nous avons besoin de cette
transversalité et que la martinique est
une véritable richesse en soi avec ses
particularités ses singularités tant
qu'originaire de lieux mais avec une
vision panoramique
même question pour vous alors
effectivement en fonction des td petit
territoire je répète la martinique c'est
petit c'est petit comme le val demande
c'est un tout petit territoire et qu'on
a effectivement les problématiques qui
parfois sont un peu différentes selon
les territoires
moi je sais que dans le sud les
problèmes d'embouteillages sont très
importants puisque je les vis tous les
jours matin et soir
donc forcément on a une approche du
terrain qui est importante mais en tant
que conseillère exécutive
j'ai eu à traiter les soixante huit
collèges et lycées de la martinique de
la même manière avec la même objectivité
et la même acuité donc un peu comme
comme marie-france je dirais que il nous
faut quand on est en tout cas elle eut
la collectivité à avoir ce regard un
petit peu entier sur la martinique
sans négliger les problématiques qui
sont inhérents à chaque territoire génie
du dispostif vous avez prononcé au moins
quatre fois le moment le rouge s'est
présenté tout à l'heure on vraiment cvg
foule chez omis de présenter mes vues à
toutes les personnes que génère la venue
visiter
nous avons l'habitude de le faire en
tout cas c'est le dernier jour
aujourd'hui puisque nous sommes le 31
janvier permettait aussi que je dis
gros coucou à cette dame qui a eu 100
ans vendredi sur le territoire c'est
magnifique et annoncer à la population
pvn que nous aurons cinq centenaire
cette année
alors c'est vrai que je suis élu de
montrouge dans le rouge qui fait le lien
entre le nord atlantique et le no
caraïbes mais je travaille d'abord pour
le monde au jeu puisque c'est ma commune
beaucoup bull renault mais je n'écarte
pas la martinique entière puisque comme
vous êtes élu mais quand vous êtes élu à
la collectivité
vous êtes élu pour une population et je
reçois le lundi des gens que la
martinique
je ne limite pas seulement au ps et au
pm et je reçois les gens de la
martinique qui ont des problématiques
parfois qu'il n'arrive pas à résoudre
avec leurs élus de proximité et je me
fais plaisir d'accueillir tout le monde
- le rouge une ville d'accueil puisque
nous sommes au monde donc je reste aussi
quelques minutes comment la population
pvn vittel sous le volcan avec alerte
face à l'est en début d'un kg étude 1
depuis début décembre depuis presque
deux mois maintenant
après la mise en alerte jaune
scientifique pour la surveillance de la
plaie oui les gens ça posait des
question j'ai été interpelé me disant
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
un moment en 2008 ou en 2004 aux on a eu
droit à un autre sur notre territoire
c'était pas la volonté de la
municipalité ni l'europe ni de ppr nous
avaient imposé l'accueil de familles
jadis sur le territoire mais nous sommes
une commune très calme avec une
population très calme également mais
quand nous avons entendu cette alerte
vigilance jaune scientifique dit on ça
nous a interpellés franchement je me
suis dit oh qu'est ce qui va se passer
est ce que les gens vont déserter notre
commune mais rapidement j'ai vu que les
choses ne sont pas allées dans ce sens
puisque il s'est tenu sur le territoire
une très belle réunion au millennium au
cours de laquelle nous avons pu débattre
avec les uns et les autres et j'ai senti
que c'était une population rassure
d'ailleurs notre de vision montréal
s'est monté son bras et défis que je
construis à l'ombre de la montagne
donc nous vivons avec notre volcan voilà
donc
un handicap avec lequel il faut il faut
vivre bien entre diallo a qualité plus
politique au sens large et nous sommes
en pleine période épidémique dans le
monde entier a lancé nick également au
point que le gouvernement français a
souhaité reporter la tenue des élections
des conseillers généraux conseillers
régionaux et des assemblées une
territoriale de corse de guyane et de
martinique au mois de juin le parlement
est en train d'en discuter le sénat a
adopté le projet de loi cette semaine ce
sera le cas la semaine du 9 mai à partir
du 9 février pour l'assemblée nationale
elle peut prendre les mêmes dates 13 et
20 juin
qu'est ce que vous en dites madame est
ce que vous pensez qu il faut être
suffisamment optimiste pour que les
élections la campagne électorale puis
les élections se tiennent en jeu où on
risque de les voir reporter également
sylvie façon le france le principe de
précaution doit prévaloir on se rappelle
des élections qui avaient été réalisés
lors de la 2019 où on a eu des cas de
personnes qui ont été contaminées en
sortant seulement de chez eux
donc faut pas qu'on recommence avec les
mêmes erreurs c'est pas que c'est pour
moi un peu difficile de je m'étais mise
en ligne de mire mars 2000 2021
donc j'ai assumé ma mission jusqu'au
mois de mai 21 de se dire que c'est
jusqu'en mars 2021
je suis prête à finir une année scolaire
mois ceux de ce que je crains c'est que
ce soit encore reporté et qu'on arrive
après à la période de réserve du des
élections présidentielles et qu'on dès
qu'on dépasse et qu'on arrive après en
2022 donc aujourd'hui une campagne
électorale menée parce qu'on a six mois
ça fait six mois depuis le 1er janvier
c'est difficile on a commencé avec bape
est en chasse nautique aux et tous les
mercredis webinaire de 17h30 à 19h pour
suivre le journal de martine première
d'ailleurs à 19 heures
mais donc tous les mercredis sur des
sujets société mais en fait c'est un peu
difficile de faire une campagne comme
nous avions l'habitude de faire un peu
dynamique parce que la campagne on l'a
construit tout au long de la mandature
ce sont les actions que vous menez qui
font que les gens confiance en vous par
mais en tout cas ce temps est nécessaire
et ça me semble un peu difficile
ils font tous le admettons que les
élections aient lieu en juin
soyons optimistes et pensons que le
les députés vont suivre les sénateurs
ont pour les 13 et 20 juin prochains ça
vous donne trois mois de plus
en gros on demande à ce que c'est de
nature à vous gêner ou en tout cas vous
faciliter la tâche
je crois qu'il faut toujours être
optimiste et qu'il faut vraiment espérer
que ces élections pourront se tenir en
jeu en sachant bien sûr que l'aspect
sanitaire ne doit pas être négligée et
il faut permettre aux électeurs et aux
électrices de pouvoir exercer leur rôle
on leur doit le ont deux voies dans les
meilleures conditions donc c'est vrai
que cet aspect sanitaire ne peut pas
être mis de côté
mais le fait effectivement que ça puisse
être reporté pour ma part et pour le
parti le ndm ne nous dérange en rien
puisque nous sommes vraiment dans
comment dirais-je dans une action
quotidienne c'est nous sommes en tant
qu'élu c'est notre action quotidienne de
rencontrer les gens d'échanger
donc pour moi ça ne pose pas de
difficulté même si c'est vrai que nous
avons toujours apprécié tous les élus je
crois après c'est son moment privilégié
la campagne électorale pour avoir autant
beaucoup plus mal encaissé on les
échange d'un petit peton fort aux vins
dire mais aujourd'hui c'est vrai que ce
temps risquent aussi de se faire dans
des conditions plus différente
il va nous falloir adapter ses preuves
comment dirais-je gêné et puis je crois
que nous avons aussi des outils nous
avons les outils nous avons les réseaux
sociaux nous avons été en net
il va falloir qu'on s'adapte et qu'on
mène une campagne aussi sur avec ses
différents ajouté
même si nous savons qu'il ya bon nombre
de gens et dans notre population qui
n'ont pas accès à tous ces outils et qui
ne maîtrise pas mais disons qu'il va
falloir s'adapter
il va falloir mettre en place des
réunions nous commençons quand même au
niveau du rdm à mettre des réunions les
cds dans des espaces plus ou moins
ouverts pas trop fait en mai en
respectant les gestes barrière puisque
nous pouvons nous réunirons tenant
compte d'un certain nombre de commandes
iej de conditions assure de
recommandation donc oui nous sommes
prêts maintenant si ça devait être
reporté nous allons
nous adapter mais je souhaite vraiment
qu'on puisse se permettre à la
démocratie de s'exprimer alors même
question pour vous madame le maire du
morne-rouge jenny dulys peut-il il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui n'ont pas de
connexion internet qu'ils ne sont pas
équipés en ordinateurs ou qu'ici c'est
le cas n'y vont pas non pas besoin des
réseaux sociaux pour vivre au quotidien
non non on n'en voit pas l'utilité ou
l'opportunité et c'est le cas de
beaucoup de personnes à bord le rouge
mais comme dans toutes les communes est
ce que ce n'est pas une difficulté pour
toucher ces personnes sans les les
outils numériques et en même temps en
s'abstenant d'aller chez elles ou en
tout cas trop souvent c'est compliqué
quand il s'est compliqué parce que c'est
une élection qui ne touchent pas une
commune c'est une élection sur la
martinique
et c'est vrai que bon avec cette crise
sanitaire
la population n'était pas prête dans sa
tête pour aller aux élections maintenant
madame ans maintenant ça a été repoussée
ça a été actée pour juin 2021 mais
personne ne dit que ça va se faire en
juin 2008 et puisque les scientifiques
même ne se prononcent pas oui ce sera en
avril le premier comité scientifique les
élections sur la martinique faire des
élections de ces conditions là ce n'est
pas facile bien sûr via les réseaux
sociaux
mais vous avez une partie des électeurs
qui aime bien le contact
j'aime bien voir le aux élus ils aiment
bien voir le candidat il ya des
ambiances qui se font autour d'une
élection donc ça va marquer un peu mais
beaucoup aussi utilisent les réseaux
donc on sera obligé de se plier à ça et
puis continuer les réunions comme nous
le faisons plus les communes le font
dans les quartiers en respectant les
gestes barrière est aussi le porte à
porte avec la population c'est ce que
nous vivons au quotidien sur le
territoire alors parlant de fracture
numérique je remercie le 26 août en
chargé de l'éducation
pourquoi parce que le mercredi il y à 27
janvier il ya quelques jours vous avez
remis ainsi que les maires des communes
concernées à des élèves de classes de 6e
du collège louis delgrès ce de saint
pierre aimé césaire d'abbas menthe et
eugène mona de marigot des tablettes
numériques dans la cadre du plan
d'équipement de la collectivité visant à
réduire cette fracture numérique et
contre ma
à ce qu on peut penser de l'extérieur il
ya beaucoup d'enfants scolarisés deux
bouts de jeunes qui n'ont pas
d'impossibilité d'avoir ces outils ou 7
ses connexions à la maison exactement il
faut rajouter aux trois établissements
vous avez nommé le collège christ de
christiane et à pierre du mont rouge de
leader dans le communiqué de la comique
de la collectivité
là je veux vraiment remercier les élus
qui sont ici ici présentés présent tous
les élus de la collectivité tous souvent
on a dans cette collectivité des gens
qui ont des ego surdimensionnés qui
disent que c'est eux qui font et moi
j'ai envie de dire qu'est ce qu'on
allait vous par exemple du président de
monsieur le président qui est souvent a
envie de ramener à l'huile et toutes les
actions en faisant comme si nous
n'existions parfois pas et donc je pense
qu'il est important de dire à la
population aujourd'hui qui vous écoute
qui nous écoute que ce sont tous les
élus tout con tout toutes obédiences
confondues tout tous partis confondus
qui ont voté pour cette à rallonge de 4
millions qui a permis l'achat de 8100
tablette et ordinateur donc tablette
pour les élèves de 6e et ordinateurs
pour les élèves de seconde c'est une
dépense conséquente est une dépense
conséquente les qui a été un petit peu à
lens avait alors là pas reconduit
rentrer quand même son l'état comme dans
l'émission politique
je vais entrer dans le vif du sujet
depuis le début de cette mandature
j'avais demandé d'accompagner les élèves
de seconde dans ce genre de dispositif
parce que j'étais très gênée que dans
toutes les régions de france
les parents d'élèves paient les livres
les régions pays est libre d un des
élèves de seconde première et terminale
et qu'en martinique nous ne payons pas
les livres et que c'était aux parents
acheter ses livres je trouve quelque
part il y avait une disparité et j'avais
demandé d'être accompagné dans ce projet
qui permettait d'avoir des livres
numériques sur les ordinateurs et
d'ainsi de gommer cette fracture au
moins au niveau des seconds je n'ai pas
été entendu parce que les budgets même
si les élus font le maximum a vraiment
pour défendre les budgets mais il ya des
choix qu'on fait puisqu'on sait qu'on a
un problème social sociétal très
important martinique
donc ces choix ont fait que je n'ai pas
pu réaliser ces projets que je qui me
tenait à coeur et on va dire que quelque
part à tout malheur il y a de bonnes
choses la crise a permis de montrer que
malgré le travail conséquent d'aidés des
techniciens du service numérique
scolaire que je remercie pendant la
période de confinement qui ont prêté des
tablettes des ordinateurs aux élèves de
seconde aux ailes aux élèves de
terminale aux élèves de troisième malgré
ça on s'est rendu compte y avait une
fracture énorme alors un moment quand
j'ai défendu sa au niveau du conseil
exécutif on m'a dit oui mais on n'a qu'à
donner aux enfants qui des parents qui
sont aux niveaux sociaux défavorisés et
moi je me suis battu contre ça pour dire
que je ne suis pas d'accord avec cette
analyse
parce que lorsque nous avons une famille
de parents qui travaillent et on va pas
faire le l'injure aux gens qui
travaillent et non plus parfois ils
n'ont qu'un ordinateur pour toute la
famille et on a des élèves par exemple
deux ou trois enfants qui ont des
courants distant ciel donc j'ai demandé
plutôt de donner un appareil le même une
tablette à tous les âges de 6e 6e 2 sec
pas 6e balle général et un ordinateur en
mise à disposition donc ça appartient
l'établissement et à eux d'organiser
pour que tu élèves du 6e et les collèges
les lycées et un ordinateur et ça je
remercie les élus et c'est moi j'ai
envie de travailler dans cet esprit là
c'est à dire c'est pas moi je fais c'est
un projet que j'ai porté mais il peut
pas être portée sans que les élus ne
votent pour lui et moi j'ai envie de
défendre sa et ses sacs et quelque part
qui me gêne un peu c'est à dire qu'on
travaille pas suffisamment en équipe et
ça je le dis ont chacun un peu dans son
secteur
et puis bon on défend comme on peut
alors qu'on pourrait avoir une vision
beaucoup plus large pourra hélas je suis
sûr que même que marie français et maé
jenifer même la mer sont d'accord pour à
travailler vers les plus fragiles de
notre société et les accompagner est
monté ensemble en compétences
il fonce tout ça c'est un bon exemple de
ce qu'il conviendrait de faire dans
l'idéal si la septème fonctionner
normalement et s'il n'y avait pas
parfois ces crises d'égotisme où c'est
une vision des sciences plaignants
comment les voix qui sont parfois
hallucinantes tous points de vue mais je
sais tout à fait je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ma collègue sylvia et vous
avez parlé de la campagne et je crois
que dans cette campagne électorale ce
qu'il faudra vraiment que les uns et les
autres sur lesquels il faudra vraiment
que les citoyens soient vigilants ce
n'est pas tant sur le programme sur les
projets parce que bon les projets et les
programmes
nous pouvons tous les mettre sur papier
mais vraiment ce qui me semble le plus
important c'est qu'elles sont les
engagements qui seront pris dans le
fonctionnement de la collectivité
ça me semble important il faut vraiment
qu'on soit attentif à ce que les uns et
les autres vont dire et de leur
conception même du pouvoir de la
conception même de la gestion de cette
collectivité parce qu'il faut vraiment
que cette collectivité dans les années
qui viennent
fonctionne vraiment comme l'a dit elle
ma collègue aussi via met vraiment en
équipe que nous soyons une équipe et
qu'il y ait actuelle et les tendances
puisque c'est vrai qui a la majorité
c'est normal que la majorité soit mieux
représentée qu'elle ait plus d'élus
puisque bon c'est la démocratie qui le
veut n'est pour autant l'opposition
aussi ce sont des gens qui ont été élus
par le peuple ils n'ont pas volé leur
place et ils on doit aussi d'être
entendus et ils on doit aussi de pour
deux des maîtres d asie et de construire
avec avec la majorité un programme et un
projet alors justement nous serons
encore dans une dans un autre débat
purement politique avec cette initiative
que vous avez prises
jenny dulys pâti à samedi dernier vous
avez réuni hommes en rouge
un certain nombre d'élus de tous bords
politiques ne presque tous les bons
politiques dans l'idée de chercher sinon
un consensus ou une union sacrée disant
des majorités d'idées sur une vision de
la martinique
non seulement penser les problèmes
qu'elle doit affronter mais surtout pour
les solutions qui doivent être mises en
face de ces problèmes donc c'est une
première initiative ce qui n' y aura une
deuxième le 6 février prochain
à rivière-pilote avec le maire de vie
opulent d'abord remercier sylvia ou sur
le travail qu'elle fait et je pense que
sylvia serait allé beaucoup plus loin
s'il y avait une autre direction une
autre commande de cette collectivité
parce que je la sens je vois qu'elle est
là des idées elle veut faire exploser
les choses sur le territoire bien sûr
vous avez comme tous les martiniquais
entendu parler de cette réunion du monde
rouge rappelez-vous en 71 il ya eu ce
qui s'appelait la con
ancien du mono jacques tous les partis
de gauche choix de look martinique
réunion guyane et ces croix sur du monde
la fameuse convention mais cette fois
avec deux amis en discutant le dit mais
pourquoi ne pas lancer une réflexion que
les gens puissent se retrouver quel que
soit le beau visuellement je n'ai pas
invité tout le monde je ne pouvais pas
inviter tout le monde mais j'ai dit vous
commencez par un petit noyau et je
remercie toutes celles et tous ceux qui
sont venus ce jour là personne n'a
trouvé que le moment où j'étais loin les
gens sont venus spontanément et les
échanges ont été très fructueux c'est
une initiative qui est qui porte
beaucoup parce que je suis incapable et
aussi dans la population c'est vrai nous
allons continuer puisque déjà c'est
programmé le 6 samedi 6 à 9 heures albi
a pilot restaurant scolaire
prefontaine a dit au pilote nous allons
retrouver bien sûr ceux qui étaient là
la première fois mais peut-être deux ou
trois qui vient de loin que le jeu nous
allons inviter également est-ce qu'il
est là courants politiques qui ne vous
n'avez pas invité volontairement ou pas
voulu inviter les grosses têtes de la
martinique les 10 c'est pas ça le but
était pas là mais cependant la porte
n'était pas fermée
il y en a qui sont venus en axant pas
venu j'avais invité tous les
parlementaires j'ai eu des excuses de
certains et à d'autres qui n'ont pas
répondu mais enfin les gens qui étaient
là c'était des gens de bonne composition
qui avait compris qu'il fallait enfin
que le rêve puisse aboutir que les
martiniquais et les martiniquais se
mettent ensemble dans l'intérêt général
puisque nous tous qui sommes en
politique quand on regarde la moyenne
d'âge ce sont des gens qui ont déjà six
ont pu le dire vécu ce sont des gens qui
ont eu une carrière professionnelle et
qui ont réussi dans la vie et qui se met
au service d'une population qui donne le
temps pour une population pour servir
rien qu'à servir j'aime le dire parce
que moi j'aime ce que je fais quand je
suis au service d'une population
j'aime les gens et je pense que se met
au service d'une population c'est une
mission que nous avons est qu'il faut
l'assumer jusqu'au bout
face à la première jan map partie
face à la première aujourd'hui avec
jenny dulys petit mais en immolant de
rouge que vous venez d'entendre membres
de l'opposition à l'assemblée de la
martinique
si jadis automne de rivière salée
membres du conseil deux membres du
conseil exécutif de la 7e et
marie-france tout le deuxième vice
présidente de l'assemblée de martin je
suis parce que on parle on parle on
passe du nord au sud en passant donc oui
c'est vraiment représentatif de notre
martinique alors précisément cette
initiative politique du numéro de rouge
est ce que si la cei tout le temps elle
vous paraît augurer d'une nouvelle donne
d'une nouvelle offre politique
oui j'ai envie de croire qu'en tout cas
les bonnes volontés se retrouve quelles
seront accompagnés de nouvelles bonnes
volontés
je crois que c'est important de sortir
un petit peu de alors on pas souvent de
kankan politique mais de sortir un petit
peu si vous voulez de 2,7 bilaté
réalisation de la vie politique en
martinique je crois qu'il faut essayer
de sortir de ça on a déjà vécu ça il y
en a deux qui trouve ça très bien
d'autres moins bien en tout cas il ya eu
des alternances donc ça montre bien que
c'était pas forcément acquis pour tout
le monde et j'ai envie aujourd'hui de
croire qu'on puisse faire autre chose
d'ailleurs il ya des élus qui étaient
présents qui ont montré qu'ils étaient
en capacité de faire bouger les lignes
de faire des choses et j'ai envie de
dire que c'est vrai que l'intérêt
général c'est parfois difficile à
entendre pour certains et certaines
d'entre nous mais en travaillant dessus
en se disant que mon l'intérêt c'est
quand même la martinique et quand on dit
en arctique ça ne fait pas trop envie de
dire ça c'est plutôt les enfants les la
martinie martin kelly martin 15 des
personnes âgées c'est ce sont les
habitants les habitants et c'est pour
cela qu'on doit valeur avoir une valeur
ajoutée et c'est ce que j'ai proposé à
la réunion de madame la maire et de
monsieur petit qui était également
présent et très heureuse de le voir
également
c'est quelqu'un un combattant c'est
quelqu'un qui a qui a su montrer qu'il
était vraiment brillante que dans son
antre dans ses analyses politiques
eh bien j'ai envie de croire que on peut
mettre en synergie les choses auxquelles
on croit
et souvent quand on parle entre nous
pour moi je vois beaucoup de choses qui
nous rapprochent et simplement en
oubliant un petit peu son ego je sais
qu'en politique les goûts est important
que c'est aussi ce qui nous porte
lego c'est aussi ce en quoi on croit et
on a envie de le mettre en avant et il
mais il faut à mon avis parfois à
s'effacer pour les
c'est le projet mûrir et le projet m
j'ai envie croire à ça il fonce tools du
rdm rassemblement démocratique pour la
martinique vous n'était pas présente en
fin de votre formation n'était pas
présente au morne-rouge n'était pas
invité en tout cas on me laisse en tant
que pas pour le moment mais comment
avez-vous comment voyez vous ce genre
d'initiative politique disons original
et assez rare dans notre histoire
politique
il faut quand même préciser que j'avais
dit que je n'étais pas n'étaient pas
présents le rdm n'a pas été invitée sauf
si nous avons été quelques chose mais le
rdm n'a pas été invité et c'est vrai que
tout ce qui est rassemblement c'est
vraiment l'essence même du rdm
rassemblement démocratique pour la
martinique donc nous sommes dans cette
dynamique de rassembler le plus large
mais autour de valeurs et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui lorsque nous avons ce
type de rassemblements qui a été proposé
par madame le maire
ça ne peut être que reçu avec beaucoup
d'intérêt et de manière très positive
puisque je crois qu'il faut que nous
soyons dans cette dynamique mais qu'il
fallait il faut vraiment que l'on met de
côté tout ce qui peut nous séparer nous
diviser nous éloigner et puis qu'on
mette en commun ce qui peut nous
rapprocher et ce qui peut nous permettre
effectivement de porter de faire avancer
notre territoire de prendre en
considération bien nos jeunes les
personnes âgées et je crois que c'est
extrêmement important parce que lorsque
quelques vous été en peine dans la rue
je ne pense pas qu'ils regardent si vous
êtes de droite de gauche de mdm ou de
coincer de me dire qu'elle a besoin
d'une information elle a besoin d'une
aide elle a besoin d'une intervention
elle a besoin que vous l'accompagnez et
c'est ce qu'elles demandent donc je
crois que c'est extrêmement important
que l'on puisse et dépasser ces clivages
je crois qu'il ya néanmoins un certain
nombre de valeurs et que nous devons
partager puisque si nous n'avons pas
quand même socle commun je pense que ça
sera difficile de fonctionner mais une
fois que nous avons posé les bases mêmes
de ce rassemblement
nous pouvons je crois nous mettre
ensemble pour reconstruire
indépendamment des appartenances
politiques
mais je n'utilise le pâtissier quelles
bases politiques pouvons nous rassembler
des personnes des personnalités des
mouvements politiques qui sont non pas
de bons politiques opposées mais en tout
cas avec une idéologie quand même assez
distinctes les uns par rapport aux
autres on alcan et ceux qui sont pour
l'indépendance nationale qui sont pour
l'autonomie avec des nuances inde
chaque fois on a su qu'ils ne sont ni
pour lui ni pour l'autre de ces options
et qui souhaitent disons d et
d'idéologie les idéologies disait le
débat politique
on a du mal à comprendre qu' on puisse
se réunion tout de même à l'umq on a des
options
j'allais dire philosophique différentes
de philosophie politique j'entends mais
il ya eu des exemples par le passé et la
convention de basse terre rappelez-vous
19 et vous avez eu d'autres éléments
aussi un moment donné vous aviez de 1988
à 1992
claude lise a géré le conseil général
avec emile morice et les choses se sont
très bien passées vous avez eu aussi
pierre petit même si les jeux ne cite
pas cet exemple en 92 lorsque pierre
petit avait été hospitalisé l'avenir
rappelez vous il avait gagné les
élections mais ils ont préféré mais toi
mais il aurait pu être premier
vice-président mais puis à petit a
préféré que ce soit un proche de
d'alfred marie jeanne qui soit le
premier président en la personne de
daniel marsin mais ils ont travaillé en
bonne intelligence
puis j'ai envie de dire que nous sommes
pas ne sommes pas des ennemis même si
nous n'avons pas les mêmes idées
politiques mais on peut se rassembler et
discuter je rappelle que nous sommes
tous là pour l'intérêt général
lorsque quelqu'un vient vous voir vous
ne lui demandez pas sa couleur politique
en tout cas moi je ne demande pas à 7
personnes tuées de quel bord politique
je ne lui demande pas non plus pour qui
tu as voté ça ce n'est pas mon problème
j'ai en face de moi un individu
l'administré qui vient me voir parce
qu'il a un problème à résoudre est ma
devise vous savez c'est quoi c'est guéri
ou parfois elle ne vient pas de moi mais
je les adopter kerio parfois soulager
souvent
et console est toujours parce que même
si vous ne donnez pas une réponse
positive à cette personne mais le seul
fait de l'avant entendu vous avez gagné
personne n'a pas besoin de plus bon
allez un peu qu'on veut mettre cela ne
peut-être jeu m'avait dit que je serais
bien 7e voilà donc je pense que c'est ce
que les gens attendent de nos élus et
ils attendent surtout qu'on termine nos
querelles nous que réa qui font ralentir
les choses et qui ne donne rien
la population entière de tous bords
politiques se dit quel jour on verra
nous une fois que la martinique est à
l'arrière pourquoi parce qu'on peut pas
se donner la main pour avancer
quand je vois que le cyclotron nous on
était les premiers
eh bien nous sommes les derniers jeunes
deviennent les derniers quand je vois
les guadeloupéens qui savent se mettre
ensemble pour faire avancer la
guadeloupe
ils n'ont pas peur de parler aux besoins
de la république et java commandes unix
et athée qui occupent des propos
politiques en martinique ne veulent pas
travailler avec le gouvernement
c'est quoi ça nous sommes dans un
département français et je pense que les
hommes et les femmes devraient continuer
à travailler d'où cette première réunion
qui sera suivie de la deuxième le sis à
laquelle j'invite toutes celles et tous
ceux qui vont entendre qu'ils ont vite
venir
je les invite à y participer pour que
puisse jaillir quelque chose qui fasse
du pied à ce pays qui est en attente
sylvain c'est une certaine vous êtes
membre d'une formation politique d'un
pays en chasse qui préside par yan
monplaisir lequel avait signé une
alliance capital travail avec guy
lordinot ça remonte déjà c'était pour
les élections législatives de 1993 et ça
n'avait pas marché mais ça crée
véritablement un coup de tonnerre dans
le ciel serein de la vie politique
donc ça veut dire qu'il y avait
plusieurs initiatives jeu quand même pas
de ce qui s'est passé avant dans notre
de guerre bon wagon venus d'autres
l'ayant inclusion à plusieurs reprises
des tentatives de rapprochement de ce
qu'on appelle encore aujourd'hui la
gauche et la droite
finalement peut-être que cette fois-ci
vous sentez que c'est le moment que tous
bords politiques confondus les élus ou
les militants politiques peuvent se
parler pour aller
vers la même le même objectif écoutez
j'ai il n'a pas parlé de 2015 mais 2015
c'était exactement ça c'est la même
chose c'était dans mes mouvements sont
montré qu'on était prêt à travailler
et d'ailleurs on a vu les résultats les
électeurs et les électrices nous ont
suivi ont réellement suivi et donc je
crois que c'est important de le dire est
effectivement je crois vraiment
aujourd'hui qu'on en tout cas moi ce que
je souhaite vraiment jamais j'appelle de
mes voeux tout ce que madame la maire a
dit c'est à dire il faut vraiment qu'on
puisse être beaucoup plus apaisé on
puisse être beaucoup plus constructif et
constructive et beaucoup plus efficace
alors je moi je dis je pars du principe
un peu quand je sais le maire de sainte
luce qui le dit souvent je pars du
principe que tout ce qui a été fait
avant a été fait est bien ou pas bien
peu importe ça a été fait ça a été
réalisée et qu'il n'est pas du tout
question qu'on détruise ce qui a été
fait et et ça je m'érige contre ça je
pense que chaque élu quel que soit le
bord politique a en tout cas j'ai envie
de croire qu'il a eue ou qu'elle a eu
envie de vrai pour le mieux de la
population avec ses son analyse
personnelle mais aujourd'hui ce qui a
été fait est fait aujourd'hui j'ai envie
de encore autre chose d'aller un peu
plus dans la modernité d'aller un peu
plus dans l'efficacité dans la
réalisation vous savez on a aujourd'hui
un peuple qui est très en attente alors
j'aime pas trop laxiste et je n'aime pas
l'assistanat qui aimait qui en attente
surtout de réalisation rapide on est
dans l'ère de l'immédiateté
voilà et donc pour moi un élu doit être
tout le temps connecté on peut pas avoir
un élu qui lorsqu'on envoie un message
sur son site le message est rejetée
parce que les adresses n'existe pas ou
parce qu'on ne peut pas l'appeler parce
que parce que mon dieu quand on est
quand on a au poste on peut pas prendre
on peut pas descendre sur le terrain
pour voir ce qui se passe nouveaux
individus masqués
en connectant c'est soit ça il doit
savoir ce qu'il se passe il doit être au
courant s'il peut pas il faut qu'ils
délèguent ne peut pas vivre hors sol un
élu ça doit vivre sur la terre avec les
problématiques des gens qu'il rencontre
tous les jours pour vous parler des
exemples réels ou de manière virtuelle
chaque personne verra puisque les gens
même après mam appelle les gens savent
les gens appellent les élus les gens
savent et les gens passent souvent
effectivement par mois alors je ne suis
pas responsable du personnel pour avoir
un rendez-vous pour pour pouvoir trouver
un travail pour pouvoir voilà donc
effectivement c'est de manière très
réelle dont je parle parce que c'est mon
expérience personnelle
il fonce tout ce genre d'initiatives
prises par jenny dulys petit et jean
françois bonneau le maire de rivière
pilote et d'autres également
est ce que c'est de nature à réussir
parce que justement on vient d'évoquer
l'exemple de 2015 où on a eu un contrat
de mandature voilà sous le terme exact
signé entre les deux tours de l'élection
territoriale des élections territoriales
de 2015 et puis finalement on voit
qu'aujourd'hui ça part dans tous les
sens la majorité a quasiment imploser
est ce que ce n'est pas encore une fois
se payer d'illusions je pense que ce qui
est le plus important dans tout contrat
notre engagement c'est le respect et à
partir du moment où vous respectez votre
engagement vous respecter la parole
donnée
vous respectez un document signé
normalement les choses devraient se
passer au mieux
et puis il ya aussi le respect de la
fonction des jeux et des autres il ya le
respect de la personne et je trouve que
malheureusement dans cette collectivité
dès le départ il y à un certain nombre
de points qui avait été actée signé
parce que c'est vrai qu'on parle du
contrat de mandature entre
avec ba pays et d'un pays en chance et
voilà le grand semblait et liliane mon
plaisir
mais avant cela avant cela il y avait un
accord entre les différentes
organisations qui composaient ce grand
semblait et notamment une à caen qui
était signée avec le mdm qui avait donc
précisé dans cet accord il était précisé
effectivement que le président de
l'assemblée devait jouer un rôle
important dans cette collectivité qu'il
devait justement mettre en avant son
expérience sa probité et qu'il devait
venir accompagner le président de
l'exécutif puisqu'on sait que claude
lise a présidé le conseil général
pendant de nombreuses années et que
marie jeanne duye c'était plus la région
donc il y avait vraiment cette ces
points cette dynamique qui avait été
actée il y avait aussi cette volonté de
préparer de préparer la relève de
préparer les nouvelles générations et je
crois que c'est nous avions respecté ses
différents engagements les choses alors
je dis pas que tout aurait été parfait
puisque c'est sûr et je pense que c'est
d'une nature est ce de bon temps qu'il y
ait assez un terme au mans des
désaccords des divergences il faut bien
on peut pas tous tout le temps d'accord
sur tout mais je pense que nous aurions
pu avancer beaucoup plus sereinement
et aujourd'hui on a bien vu que le
non-respect de certaines nombre
d'engagements alors que nous étions tous
sur la même liste
nous avons tous été élus le même jour
et tout d'un coup et c'est vrai ce que
sylvie à dire ben y en a certains qui
ont considéré qu'il était le centre du
monde et que c'est eux qui devaient tous
deux courent prendre les commandes et
que les autres n'avaient plus
d'importance les autres élus n'avait
plus d'importance et n'avait plus brillé
l'indien alors jenny dulys petit si je
vous comprends bien peut-être que je
vais trop vite en besogne
tant qu'à faire si tous les élus peuvent
se mettre d'accord sur une vision sur la
résolution d'un problème sioule
d'identification de ces problématiques
on va vers une liste unique
ça martin luther king mais ça pourrait
être le rêve et c'est vrai bon les
collègues ont souligné les des
dysfonctionnements au sein de cette
collectivité
ils sont énormes et sylvia disait par
exemple que les gens l'appellent de tout
beau des gens de toutes les communes
viennent la voix ou l'interpellent sous
des douches et qui sont bloqués moi
c'est peut-être que j'ai eu une chance
une malchance d'avoir siégé d'avoir
siégé au conseil général et à la région
cette année des commissions qui se
réunissaient régulièrement je suis
membre de la commission logement
je n'ai jamais vu qu'au présent une
liste de demandes dead d'administrer à
sa commission logement commence on
attribuer les aides
est-ce que ça se fait en petit comité je
ne sais pas aucun de ceux qui sont en
commission commission double en
commission sur lui dire on se réunit
quelques jours avant la plénière passe
de plus on vous dit prenez le dossier
dans le dossier de la blinière moi je
dis qu'on aurait pu avoir des taux des
changes des temps de discussion pour
aborder les problèmes de la martinique
quand vous appelez pour le dossier de la
pac quelqu'un vient vous voir dans votre
bureau vous dit j'ai déposé un dossier
de la pac comme je réclame on m'a dit ça
n'existe pas je prends mon téléphone
combien de coups de fil avant d'avoir
quelques en vue du coût du téléphone
je vais bien qu'il y ait cette pandémie
mais en fait nous sommes un service
public
je n'ai jamais autant travaillé de ma
vie depuis le confinement je n'ai pas
arrêté je n'ai pas pris un jour de congé
à ce cas je sais qu'il ya une souffrance
et qu'il faut être au service de cette
population
et quand on perd le dossier il faut que
la personne va commencer on m'a même
demandé quand j'ai enfin eu quelques
elle m'a dit est ce que vous n'avez pas
gardé leurs doutes du dossier dit mon
dieu ça fait du coup on le cache et un
deuxième exemple ma fille m'a dit ils
ont perdu le dossier de ma main et elle
veut un accent père qui est déjà bien
fatigué donc je les reçois la emma 10
ont perdu le premier de ces musées
dépose un deuxième voilà là je prends
mon téléphone je préfère 30 minutes a
appelé à attendre quelqu'un au bout du
fil
quand enfin une bonne personne je ne
sais pas si elle me dit attendez je
vérifie elle vérifie elle m'a dit
effectivement j'ai trouvé lui aussi
alors j'ai dit je vous demande aux
services fiscaux
vous pouvez faire monter seul aussi
parce que le dossier était arrivé
sterbak on l'a réceptionné
mais après ça de gagné mais à la
souffrance qui à côté comment vous
soulager cette personne qui vit seul et
le monsieur madame les deux personnes
nous sommes fatigués ils ont besoin
d'être accompagnés alors vous venez ça
c'est un exemple du dysfonctionnement
administratif mais en coin les élus
peuvent être responsables
voilà quand il ya des élus qui sont
responsables des commissions qui ont qui
sont vice-présidents ou qui sont
conseillers exécutifs et qui si vous
avez trop de change il faut partager
choisissez des gens avec lesquels vous
pouvez faire avancer mais ne pas tout
garder
et puis in fine et bien on a une
population en souffrance oui c'est les
animaux tandis le problème vraiment je
pense que on aurait pu tenir la route
jusqu'au bout mais c'est le problème de
centralisation et c'est vraiment ça le
problème c'est le fonctionnement
lui-même dans dans la pensée et lorsque
la lefp dit lorsqu'on est centralisé
d'en haut et que ça descend dans les
services et la même chose c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui tout est cloisonné
je vous donne un exemple l'éducation
l'enseignement supérieur et la formation
tout ça fait partie de la même direction
donc elles normalement on aurait dû
avoir un seul élu pour diriger ces trois
éducation et enseignement supérieur et
formation
au début je suis arrivé vous savez déjà
j'étais pas très favorable à l'union
finalement je suis rentré quand même à
cannes et j'ai pris ce qu'on m'a donné
on arrive on est un minoritaire on a
peut-être été peut-être pas assez
vigilants à mon avis au début mais c3 c3
et principe ils sont séparés en 3 c'est
à dire qu'une seule direction est séparé
par la formation avec monsieur marie
sainte qui a dit très tôt ça c'est mon
bébé je veux la formation
professionnelle on a dû donner à
m'amener là parce qu'elle arrivait un
peu comme moi on lui a donné des
toitures à l'enseignement supérieur et
l'âge le jeu est dit et toi tu auras les
collèges et les lycées
au début ils vont 68 c'est beaucoup mais
quand on regarde sur la philosophie même
politique
on peut pas dissocier les uns des autres
c'est impossible de mener un projet sans
mener la formation l'enseignement
supérieur et éducation
aujourd'hui on accroît zone et en trois
et on assure chargé d'aider des conseils
but d'éduquer exécutif
mission qui parfois mais j'ai envie de
dire les dépasse parce qu'on a des gens
qui ont en charge de tellement grosse
direction plusieurs grosses direction
qu'ils sont un peu comme des ministres
je sais que c'est ce qui avait été
peut-être pensé au début mais on avait
la chance d'avoir une assemblée avec des
élus qui étaient prêts à travailler est
prête à travailler et souvent au début
ça a beaucoup
vous n'avez pas suis ça mais ça a
beaucoup free splitter au début parce
que les les commissions 10ème et méo
peut être force de proposition moi j'ai
une commission jeu et dès le début j'ai
essayé alors au début ça aussi c'est pas
facile on s'est arrangé avec la
commission éducation pour que je les
associe à tout ce que je faisais pour
qu'on soit ensemble qu'ils soient même
niveau d'information mais ça n'a pas été
le cas pour tous les conseils exécutifs
moi je dis les gens qui pensent qu'ils
ont le pouvoir ils n'ont pas compris ce
que ça veut dire
le pouvoir c'est le pouvoir de faire les
choses et ça anime le pouvoir de faire
les choses
face à la première
[Musique]
nous approchons de la fin de notre
émission face à la première aujourd'hui
avec silva side souten comme on veut
notre membre du conseil exécutif chargé
de l'éducation et jenny dulys petit mais
rendement en rouge conseillère dans
l'opposition à l'assemblée de martin qui
font tous le deuxième vice président de
l'assemblée
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait changer madame
toul pour que les choses aillent mieux
dans pour le prochain le prochain mandat
qui devrait commencer
théoriquement en juin faisant comme si
quelles que soient les personnes qui
sera de membres de l'assemblée même du
conseil exécutif
comment l'institution peut-elle se
s'améliorer se renouveler je pense qu'il
faut vraiment qu'on soit dans la co
construction
l'écolo conseil exécutif l'exécutent
effectivement il a une mission il a un
rôle
il a une fonction l'assemblée aussi à
ses prérogatives et je crois qu'il faut
donner aux uns et aux autres les moyens
de fonctionner l'assemblée donnent un
certain nombre d'orientations
l'assemblée comment dirais je vote le
budget d'ailleurs parce que certains ont
l'impression que tout vient du conseil
exécuté mais c'est l'assemblée qui vote
le budget qui votent les orientations
budgétaires
même si le président du conseil exécutif
il a la compétence du de gérer le
personnel
mais lorsqu'il s'agit de faire un
certain nombre d' ouvrir un certain
nombre de postes de fermeture des postes
tout cela doit être voté au niveau de
l'assemblée quand on parle par exemple
du patrimoine c'est de la compétence
effectivement la gestion du patrimoine
c'est de la compétence de l'exécutif est
poussé à des travaux mais il faut que
l'assemblée aussi vote pour le budget
pour pouvoir faire des travaux donc vous
voyez bien qu'il faut qu'on soit
vraiment dans cette co construction pour
pouvoir avancer il faut donner à
l'assemblée moyenne justement de pouvoir
rejouer véritablement son rôle en rôle
devait dire de contrôle mais aussi comme
signal a dit c'est important parce que
tout de suite lorsque nous sommes
arrivés les élus de la sambre de
l'assemblée les responsables de
commissions
les présidents de commission ont dit
voilà que nous sommes prêts à vous
accompagner nous sommes prêts nous
sommes disponibles
nous recevons nous avons la possibilité
de faire remonter de faire ce lien entre
vous
et la population parce que vous imaginez
petit noyau ne peut pas gérer tous les
problèmes de la martinique je trouvais
dit qu'il ya une coupure entre le
conseil exécutif et les jets cette
commission il ya dix sept comédiens je
vais pas dire tous les conseillers
exécutifs que ça fonctionne ainsi parce
qu'il ya certains exécutifs avec
lesquels on travaille très bien on
échange on les appelle ils nous
appellent bon je vois par exemple bon
c'est pas parce que c'est si vieille
parce qu'elle est là mais en tant que
représentante de la collectivité dans
certains établissements scolaires
lorsque je fais me remonter un certain
nombre de demandes d'informations ça
fonctionne bon après c'est vrai que elle
elle est peut-être bloqué un prêt pour
me donner les informations
mais tout ce qu'elle peut me donner
elles me donnent bon donc oui il ya
certains conseillers exécutifs avec
lesquels ça fonctionne je veux pas dire
que tout le monde va l'amener là aussi
j'ai très bien travaillé madame eux
comme ils s'appellent torino marine est
aussi j'ai très bien fonctionné avec
voilà donc il ya des exécutifs avec
lesquels ça fonctionne très bien
par contre on voit bien qu'à certains
moments il y a effectivement cette
fraction mêmes lens que en tant qu'élu
vous vous rendez compte que vous êtes
élu delà de la collectivité vous êtes
deuxième vice président de l'assemblée
vous recevez un administré vous faites
remonter une doléance
vous n'avez même pas vous de réponse de
savoir si le dossier a été pris en
compte
c'est la personne lui a répondu on vous
répond pas vous ne savez pas et donc
cette personne vous rappelle qu est ce
que vous pouvez lui dire qu'est ce que
vous pouvez lui dire a pas j'ai envoyé
là au bon et puis quand c'est arrivé là
haut on n'a pas de retour donc ce qui
fait que c'est extrêmement difficile
pour pouvoir retravailler et donc moi je
crois qu'il faut qu'on soit vraiment
dans cette co construction qu'on
travaille avec un esprit de mettre en
avant la démocratie et c'est pas
trois pieux et cette démocratie va
vraiment permettre me semble-t-il d'être
efficace parce qu'on ne peut pas tout
sens très concentré dans les mains d'un
petit noyau ce n'est pas possible
jenny dulys petit pour le dernier les
derniers mots les dernières phrases de
l'émission est ce que vous êtes candidat
pour un nouveau mandat ou vous laisser
la place à d'autres vous n'avez pas
encore pris votre décision
je pense que j'ai encore un rôle à jouer
dans cette martinique et que la
martinique a besoin de moi je vous
disais que je suis une femme de mission
et je pense que le moment est venu
justement ce que j'ai entrepris de faire
avec doute appeler au rassemblement
ce moment qui est venu ce moment faut
que nous attendons je pense qu'il faut
le faire mais je veux parler et terminer
les missions sans parler de la
démocratie souligné la collègue
c'est vrai que moi j'ai eu à vivre je le
dis parce qu'il faut qu'on imagine
qu'elle le sache
j'ai eu à interpeller deux conseillers
exécutifs ou des questions relevant de
leur compétence et chaque fois la
réponse qui m'a été donné il faut voir
le président lui-même ce que j'ai fait
j'ai appelé le directeur des services
j'ai dit voilà le problème que je
rencontre et je vous donne une réponse
immédiate
dans la seconde le président mabri
la question a été résolue mais je pense
que ça ne devrait pas être si vous êtes
dans l'exécutif
il faut partager le conseil exécutif
doit avoir la capacité de répondre le
président semble également il doit avoir
des moyens lui permettant de bien gérer
de de bien porter sa mission donc tous
ces petits problèmes tous ces
dysfonctionnements font que nous
d'essayer new day compte allonger m'a
dit aux gens il faut avancer
et puis ce que j'ai envie de dire
également dès le départ j'avais senti
qu'il y avait des petites choses qui
n'est pas loin lorsqu'il s'était agi de
désigner
même si c'est le président de la
collectivité qui devait normalement
siéger au congrès
des conseils départementaux de la ive je
ne sais pas si vous vous appelez
tragédie mais pourquoi on ne donne pas
cette mission à produise parce que pour
moi aujourd'hui claude lise a été
président du conseil général
il s'est beaucoup occupé des affaires
sociales et sa place et elle a donc on
lui a pas donnée et une dernière chose
que je voulais dire
nous avons signé une convention de
territoire avec le président de la
collectivité
et c'est vrai que il faut que nous
puissions bousculer pour que les choses
puissent continuer à avancer
ça avance mais pas suffisamment et j'ai
envie de terminer en vous disant
beaucoup de choses ont été faites en
cinq ans on peut pas cracher dessus
quel que soit l'élu quelle que soit la
commune je le dis tout le temps on peut
pas remédier aux communes affiliées
chacun travaille à son rythme des choses
ont été faites dans cette collectivité
oui mais pas suffisamment on peut mieux
faire
on peut mieux faire en prenant l'argent
de l'europe on peut me faire un point
dans tous les plans de relance tout ce
qui est mis à notre disposition
et puis booster vous avez des gens qui
attendent dans le social par exemple
quand vous voyez que pour le
fonctionnement du ccas ya une somme
obligatoire qui est inscrite en vous la
verse deux ans après mais la population
qui est dans le besoin
elle n'attend pas donc les communes qui
m'a pas de grosse capacité financière
voyez le gramme
heureusement qu'il y à beaucoup d'élus
qui ont le coeur sur la main
ça permet de soulager beaucoup de
personnes pendant deux jours on vous dit
l'euro/dollar l'europe c'est notre
argent puisque ce sont les contribuables
qui alimente le budget des états membres
viennent et qui est lui même un big lots
n'ayons pas peur absolument mais s'il ya
cette scène vous êtes candidate pour les
six prochaines années
bien sûr bien sûr je suis candidate fut
un temps j'ai hésité parce que j'étais
parfois un peu déçu j'avais même dit que
ici la nôtre en tant que vous allez
arrêter la politique déçu à ce moment
c'est un revers dans certaines élections
mais comme quoi finalement vous savez ce
que je dis c'est que ça n'engage que moi
cette parole parce que c'est moi seul
qui ai mes nuits blanches c'est moi seul
qui vais avoir les problèmes à gérer si
je me réengage et aujourd'hui je me dis
que oui il faut que j'y aille un peu
comme a dit jenny je pense que c'est
important il ya beaucoup de gens qui me
demandent de continuer j'ai envie
continuer parce que j'ai plein de
projets à faire et j'espère vraiment
inauguré le lycée paulette nardal et le
collège mendy françois élie voici encore
un sujet qui m'a fait trop
alors bonne ambiance et du cos le lycée
du cos entre éléments dit françois lis
le collège passe d'un voici encore un
exemple aujourd'hui j'ai appris qu'il y
avait des réunions de travail de copines
pour l'inauguration qui doit se faire à
une date que je ne connais pas alors que
je suis élu en charge de l'éducation
voyez un exemple c'est ça m'a un peu
renversé parce que c'est encore une fois
on tire la couverture moi je suis pas de
cet esprit moi j'ai envie de dire ballon
prendre des couvertures si on a besoin
de couvertures pour se chauffer mais
allons tous ensemble travail et c'est en
ça que je crois en france que vous avez
déjà pris votre décision pour un nouveau
mandat ou vous attendez encore un peu
non je suis candidate 1 pour la
prochaine collectivités comme mes
collègues l'ont dit moi je suis
pleinement investi dans mes missions
j'aime beaucoup ce que je fais c'est à
dire c'est en vient à la population
parce que c'est vraiment pour cela que
je me suis engagé en politique
accompagné les plus les plus démunis
mais c'est aussi de cette envie de faire
progresser d'aller en avant d'entrer
dans les nouvelles technologies amener
mon pays beaucoup plus loin beaucoup
plus plus haut
et puis je crois fermement que on peut
mieux faire
parce que c'est vrai que nous avons
cette collectivité nous avons fait
beaucoup de choses
je crois qu'on a travaillé même deux
fois parce que ce qu'on aurait pu faire
autre est simplement on a dû mettre deux
fois plus d'énergie
donc on est peut-être plus fatigués et
au bout mais on l'a fait vraiment avec
beaucoup de conviction beaucoup de force
beaucoup d'un mot je vais le dire aussi
et beaucoup de bienveillance pour
certains en tous les cas pour moi c'est
ainsi que j'ai eu plaisir à exercer et
que j'ai plaisir à exercer mon mandat
d'élu et je crois que nous avons
vraiment
fait beaucoup malheureusement nous
aurions pu faire beaucoup plus et mieux
et dans un autre état d'esprit
parce que je vois et serena parler des
fonds européens n'est pas que des
fourgons paient on voit pour l'emploi en
fait voilà les investissements il ya de
grosses difficultés des gros problèmes d
des conceptions qui s'affrontent et je
crois et je trouve inadmissible que l'on
puisse aujourd'hui thésauriser de
l'argent tout ce qu'ils aient des
montants ou annoncés parfois on va voir
sur le compte administratif d'un peu de
mal à sortir le compte administratif
quoi passer de 5 millions nous voilà que
son perroquet 210 euros stocker et puis
calais vers soir sans qu'il y ait à riom
voilà qui l'y a en face des gens qui
sont en difficulté des collèges qui ne
sont pas encore entrer vraiment dans une
autre et on y sent qu'il agit du monde
alors vraiment soit vous voyez par
exemple passé je mange pas sur la route
des religieuses et je vois les gens qui
vont vraiment qu'ils sont dans une
situation extrêmement critique voilà
lorsque vous voyez des gens qui viennent
vous voir et qu'ils y arrivent et qui
ont les larmes aux yeux qui sont dans
les chefs d'entreprise
moi je me dis non c'est ccc est grosse
et trop nous sommes partis pour une
seconde émission mesdames c'est d'abord
une réalité puisque le 6 à 6 février et
bien vous souhaitez éviter à cette
réunion bernard mais pour l'invitation
nous serons vous serez invité à nouveau
dans quelques semaines dans face à la
première cet essai en tout cas que celle
du jour se conclut avec adèle doué et
guides qui auront lieu à la réalisation
vous retrouverez l'émission partie de
deux messieurs notre podcast de notre
site internet martinique pour la
première point fr à quelques instants
les dernières informations avec le
journal de la rédaction de martinique la
première je vous donne rendez vous
dimanche prochain puis avant de vous
donner congé
une petite phrase que j'ai tirée d'un dj
l'un des livres de manga thatcher en
politique si vous voulez des discours
demandé à un homme si vous voulez des
actes demander à une femme c'est
exactement ça met un peu sexiste nous
vivons continue
mais c'est celle de la population
ressent de plus en plus si à bientôt
merci face à la première
[Musique]